staving off boredom that's what's
keeping Sony boma busy he planned to be
in Europe by now eight months ago he set
out from his native Sierra Leone but
he's stranded in Agadez in leisure in a
camp set up by the International
Organization for Migration the life is
not easy at all we are stuck up you know
nabe been talking to Iowa em to see how
best they can help was to go back home
even for me you know I don't really want
to go home I don't have an itch I don't
have a choice during his visit Germany's
Development Minister GERD mother listens
to Sony's story as well as other
migrants stories and all these people of
Libya Kosta Kosta praising you have to
pay some money will you be free my
people send our money through connection
decoders yes no pain no pain is waking
such a connection the money went to
Libya in I was free and I came back here
to find a way back home
as Monty does my vows when you look at
these faces and speak to the young
people you see what hopelessness means
they want nothing more than a future to
work and to be able to survive in most
cases an entire family of 20 30 or 50
people are depending on this young man
to deliver for them the off season
Island young and man bound on jetson
Melo wants to understand what's driving
migration to combat it with development
aid where possible migrants from West
Africa pass through new share on route
to Europe every Monday a convoy sets out
for Libya countless numbers died
traveling through the desert and at
least 3,000 people have drowned this
year alone in the Mediterranean Germany
assists the voluntary return of migrants
by funding the IOM 600 are currently
waiting in Agadez for papers from their
embassies before they can return home
many of the migrants are angry they fail
to get to Europe and now they're stuck
here in agadez some of them are also
ashamed of returning to their families
empty-handed
Sonny boomer is not his family are
thrilled he is returning under no
circumstances does he want to go back to
Libya I miss oh yes of course I miss my
family I miss crickets they are happy
because some people lose the life and
I'm successful in that way so I have to
go back home they are happy the brown
boy must and $1,800 trying to reach
Europe now though he just wants to look
forward to start working for himself as
a trader in Sierra Leone and be with his
family once again